Sunday afternoon in northern Rio in
madera a man and a smartphone nothing
else is necessary for a media ninja live
report it's broadcast live over the
Internet and anyone who once can watch a
change of scene sao paulo these are what
could be considered the editorial
offices of media ninja everyone's
constantly on the internet more
precisely on social networks because
they're the only places the ninjas
reports videos and live streams appear
they don't even have their own website
reporters see themselves as activists
they earn nothing they're working for
what they consider a just cause media
ninja came to public notice a good eight
months ago with the countrywide
demonstrations voy cuando una festa so a
sequence a cumulative our coverage of
the mass protests and street campaigns
people began to notice us HP come won't
be careless power they were looking for
alternative information so different
from what the traditional media were
broadcasting vehicles Tritonia media now
many of them identified with media
ninjas coverage de cobertura key a media
initiative of a zine tens of thousands
followed the brutal police attacks
online doing magic for you a NOSSA stage
go ahead that's our aesthetic that view
from the stream is that of the
demonstrators I'm a [ __ ] its
characteristic of mídia ninja I mean I
don't think it makes us vulnerable
because we still have the responsibility
to show what's happening Stan's not
distort events hang up without talking
to sing on the contrary I think that
gives us even more legitimacy he
Argentina meisa in de propiedad privada
sobre callup out
using new platforms inventively the
climate is favorable for alternative
media in Brazil's urban centers such as
South Paulo there's a need for more and
for more diverse information whether or
not it's more balanced information is
that important it's certainly important
for the people who founded publica their
idea an agency for investigative
journalism with 11 staff reporters their
stories appear on the agency's website
and also in more than 70 daily
newspapers and on popular internet
services the principal publica donates
its content it can do so because it's
funded by international bodies and isn't
under pressure to produce penguin
tomorrow kuya put a super demand for
this kind of journalism is much greater
than people thought in a traditional
commercial model these reports cost a
lot of money but they're essential to
our democratic process and the big
debates in our country says they sell
for the Boche Democrat for instance our
series on mega investments in
infrastructure projects in the Amazon
can have a huge impact phase sub
Jamaican vish means namaz o.m.g Mostro
grands impacts a job when research like
that is posted on the internet the
response is enormous the reports are
used reused discussed tweeted and shared
a lot compartir odd
the platform reporter Brazil and its
founder Leonardo Sakamoto also have
investigative ambitions it was launched
in 2001 since that time many studies on
the linkage between the economy and the
environment have appeared among the
alternative online media the staff at
reporter Brazil are already old hands
Leonardo Sakamoto is also an influential
bloggers his voice is in even more
demand since the wave of protests over
the protest when the people demonstrate
the response is but aren't Brazilians
usually happy and don't they love the
party what's happening I think it was
kind of a warning hid with the message
we stopped we may have grown
economically ortho can't achieve some
improvements but we're far behind when
it comes to civil rights for large
segments of the population per hour mark
box level plus some time and again
reporter Brazil exposes dangerous
working conditions they covered a
countrywide study of Brazilian
slaughterhouses whose meat is sold in
150 nations through global retail chains
as a large emerging nation with major
sporting events approaching Brazil has
awakened many expectations perhaps too
many says Sakamoto but as Yucatan
astellas oil could ease when it comes to
Brazil's image abroad then it's either
Christ ascending or Christ in free fall
I think the ascent was never real nor is
the free fall let's be slightly more
precise not so euphemistic but also not
so pessimistic we're in the midst of a
process and these new media that are
growing are being created if I more
important can I ask you that because
they advance that process sportage
preform intense process
one thing the new media have in common
they're banking on a society that wants
to make a difference and challenge its
country